Got It.
I try to balance my life as best I can.
I don't go through airport scanners as much as I can and have rays.
Uh,
these little things.
Do you think those are bad for you?
Those are the new ones.
Aren't they like a radio wave?
Yeah,
they're,
they're millimeter radio waves.
I don't want to take chances and also don't want to freak people out.
But the old style ones that were banned in Europe first,
they were potentially damaging.
Um,
is definitely,
uh,
try not to have as many as you can,
but flying is oh,
just as bad as an x ray.
Well that's the problem.
Um,
that was going through a scanner and I said,
I don't want to get through the scanner.
And they got quite upset cause it's a bother.
But,
uh,
they said,
you know,
it's just as much,
uh,
damage to your body as the flight.
And so I said,
why do I want to double it anyway,
so I,
I through three scanners,
but I try not to,
but let me tell you why I think it's so bad because scan is going to change.
Uh,
what we call the epigenomes.
Now a lot of people haven't heard of the epigenome.
The genome,
everybody knows it's your DNA.
Uh,
the code of life,
the epigenome is what regulates and reads those genes at the right time.
Okay?
And so we've,
we knew about DNA,
we know how to read the genome pretty easily.
We can do that now on a Mars bar sized device in a day.
Uh,
the epigenomes quite different,
different.
The epigenomes is that the structure of how the DNAS looped around?
If you look at the chromosome,
you're not seeing the genome,
you'll probably basically saying epigenomes and what w what I think is causing
aging is not that you're losing the DNA structure,
you're not having mutations.
You're actually changing the epigenome,
which is the,
the reader of the genes to put another way,
a compact disc,
okay.
Uh,
for the young audience,
uh,
come back,
discs are little things we used to put music on.
Uh,
but anyway,
these are,
these are digital information of course.
And the reason we switched to digital in the first place is that it's very
copyable and it doesn't wear out.
Whereas a cassette tape,
you know,
people our age know that if you try to copy that a thousand times,
there's not much left at the end.
So the,
the Compact disc inflammation is the genome.
The epigenome is the reader of the CD.
That little laser that goes around,
and what I think is causing aging is not the loss of the digital information,
but it's the reader,
the analog part.
And that's like a cassette tape that eventually runs out.
So what we,
what's going on really is that yourselves are losing the ability to read the
right genes the way they did when you were 20,
and that's basically noise,
informational noise that gathers over time.
Um,
and so what we end up with when we're 80 is a compact disc or DVD that
scratched.
So the reader cannot read the right genes,
the right time,
and the cells become dysfunctional.
Now what we're working on is highly Polish,
that CD or that DVD to get that information back again.
And if you can do that,
I think that's really the best way to reset your age.
And I,
I,
we haven't published it yet,
but,
uh,
we're working on ways to actually reset that genome and actually get back the
information that we once had when we were 20.
So what is happening to the epigenome when you're going through those scanners?
Well,
so what we found is the biggest disruptor of the epigenome is,
uh,
a broken chromosome,
DNA break and run about scanners.
That's just an abundance of caution.
But an x ray will damage your DNA,
no question.
Um,
even going out in the sun will do a bit of that.
And we think that the cells reaction to that break having to unwrap the DNA from
its Chromatin,
we call it,
and uh,
and then rewrap it is what eventually disrupts the ability to read the right
gene at the right place.
So Dna damage is essentially a little scratch on,
on the DVD,
and that accumulates over time.
So being out in the sun does the app of being out in the sun also is beneficial.
Your body produces more vitamin D.
Yeah,
well that,
so there's also a theory called antagonistic pleiotropy,
which is what's good for you when you're young comes back to bite you in your
old,
ah,
so you might look good and feel good and get vitamin D when you're young.
But the accumulation of these scratches on the Epi genome ends up,
you know,
I'm formerly an,
an Australian originally in Australia now,
American and Australian.
Uh,
I grew up in this straight and son.
And I can tell you that,
you know,
most Australians look older than they should.
No ozone,
uh,
no ozone and lack of sunscreen in the 1970s.
Why do you guys have a whole nose on over Australia?
What's that all about?
What'd you do?
Uh,
no.
It's what,
what did the world to chlorophyll or it ashore?
Uh,
well,
hairspray,
why does it accumulate over Australia is,
or a theory.
It started in Antarctica and a,
so ozone will,
that'd been convenient.
Nobody's up there.
Leave it up there.
Yeah.
Well if you need a break,
Leonid below it that way.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
the,
the ozone layer is fairly important.
Uh,
if you don't want to get singed by UV light.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well that's one of the first things I noticed when I went to Australia was a,
there's all these sun cancer warnings,
skin cancer warnings everywhere.
Well,
a third of Australians get some performance kissed skin cancers.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
But what's also gonna happen is it'll disrupt your epigenomes over time and
you'll look old.
Um,
but if you'd have an x Ray,
you're gonna damage your organs.
You can accelerate aging,
I believe in your body.
Um,
and it happened.
You can't avoid double strand breaks.
Crump,
broken chromosomes happens all the time.
There's trillions of cells in your body and it's happening all the time.
So living is a problem.
Okay.
Flying,
flying is even worse about we're working on is how do you get back that original
information into the cell and make a sell?
Not just believe that it's 20 again,
but actually be 20.
So what do you do?
We reprogram them.
There are a set of genes that we,
we and others have found,
uh,
three main ones that when you put them into a or even into a mouse,
they become younger again.
Whoa.
How far do you think you are from implementing this on human beings?
Uh,
well,
so theoretically,
uh,
are you doing it to yourself?
You could do it to yourself.
Theoretically I would.
I wouldn't do that because I'm not crazy.
We need to figure out the safety.
I don't want to become a giant tumor.
Why would just use it on bad people?
Uh,
yeah.
Well take,
keep knocking on that tournament.
18 year olds and go,
whoa.
Yeah.
Well yeah,
that,
that would be for someone else.
Someone else.
Well,
hopefully no one would ever do that.
Why not?
Well would kill him.
His is what we're doing.
I agree with you that we want it.
We want to see what happens in humans.
Just give them like free pizza or something.
They're on death row,
right?
If you're there already murderers,
you want to be the first one to me,
come on my lab,
death row and I want to go into death row,
but I'm saying if you're going to kill somebody,
like wouldn't be a good idea to like go,
hey,
we'll give you a four hours of TV a day,
so we want to shoot you up with some stuff.
It's going gonna make a younger.
If I was on death row,
I'd go do it.
See what's up.